69 I should be my
insurance
69 okay so you said you're heading to uh
Carthage yeah okay and you're coming
from Walmart yeah okay do you have it in
your phone
or um I'm yeah okay where's your phone
taking you to Carthage to Carthage okay
gotcha all right you can have
that unless you're looking for a
possible
okay all right uh let me get some
current information from you y uh how
long have you lived here
where you staying at I guess I'm staying
at car okay I got you sorry I'm
not okay got
it what's your uh current address like
home address or where I'm wherever
you're getting mail I guess um it's
shoot I don't even know the
Cur and then my name is
k
okay
sorry gotcha it's really hard for
dominoes to deliver this so I'm like
it's super hard like to like even order
at
this building like it's it sucks but
sure okay sounds good all right just
stay in the car I'll be right back okay
okay no
worries she's um heading to Carthage oh
from Walmart okay so
yeah hey Kiara hi how's it going it's
doing pretty good how are you I'm doing
pretty good I'm officer trip at the
kosha police department so I know my
partner talked to you what's what's
going on today where you coming from um
I'm coming from Walmart from Walmart
okay where I'm trying to go to C College
back
to
okay so here's the thing um we got a
couple indicators I want to just make
sure you're good to drive and get home
tonight
obviously um just so that you're safe
would you mind stepping out doing some
SFS with me some standard field soety
tests
[Music]
okay right just real quick since I stand
with you mind if I just pat you down so
you don't have any weapons or anything
here what I'll do is I'll have you just
stand right by the car face towards the
car for me put your hands behind your
back you're not under arrest or anything
it's just how I'm going to do this okay
I just want to make sure you don't got
any
weapons okay so for the first test what
we'll do you want to walk over here with
me you can stand on the sidewalk right
here okay thank
you so I'll kind of explain the test go
through explaining them to you we'll get
you in position get you ready to do
everything and then we'll go through
with them okay all right so for this
first test what I'm going to have you do
I'll have you stand with your feet
together arms out at your sides like
this and stay in this position okay you
got that do you have any questions with
that positioning no worries all right so
for this first test I'm going to check
your eyes using your eyes and your eyes
only I want you to follow the tip of my
finger so keep your nose pointed towards
me don't move your head I'm going to
move it side to side just follow the tip
of my finger okay okay do you have any
questions with that do you understand do
you have anything wrong with your eyes
like crazy like a major like a glass eye
or anything crazy like that nothing no
you're good okay all right so again just
follow the tip of my finger stay in that
position okay highspeed chases we got up
unruly suspects I will kill that mother
me no do it stay in the Box I like it
dramatic DUI I'mma pass everything that
she trying to do and shocking body cam
footage hey get on the ground get on the
ground law on crime presents body cam
the place for real raw and wild police
videos you should have seen it it was
good it's on body cam I'll show it to
you catch the action and subscribe to
our new YouTube channel
[Music]
now on tilting your chin down just a
little bit for me perfect
[Applause]
one two
7 28
victory
okay well do one more I'm just going to
go up follow it the same thing you've
been doing okay set your chin down a
little bit I know it's going to kind of
hurt when I bring my finger all the way
up but sorry no you're good so we'll
start right
[Applause]
here okay good so that's the first test
we're going to do we got two more okay
okay so for the second one I'm going to
have you look at the sidewalk right here
you can kind of see there's nothing in
the way no like debris anything that's
going to trip you up right so I'm going
to have you imagine that there is a
straight line just extending out from
here all the way along there straight
imaginary line okay from where just
right in front of you one second tilted
right we'll do it in the we'll do it in
the road okay you can either go up there
just for for your best like your best
shot at it just cuz I don't want to mess
you up um the this is kind of slanted
downward angle walk so we'll walk down
know do to wherever he goes to no so
here's here's the thing I'll explain
everything to you the thing is is this
is kind of caned I don't want that to
mess up the test right okay so is that
better flat up there or you just want to
do it right in between here that should
be good all right do you want to step
towards me then so I'll have you stand
right where I'm standing right in front
of the car all
right so as you can see this is more
flat than that sidewalk right okay it's
kind of flat like that there's nothing
no debris nothing's going to trip you up
in the way right no do you have anything
wrong with with your legs like a peg leg
anything crazy like that nothing you're
all good okay perfect so what I'm going
to have you do for this test just like
the other one there's going to be a
starting position so I want you to put
your imagine that like a straight line
going to the bumper of your car and
going back right so on that imaginary
line put your left foot on
it so there's your left one sorry then
take your right foot put it in front of
your left foot touch and heel the toe
like this and then keep your arms down
at your sides just like how we did for
the other one okay so hold on I'll
explain it to you no you're good so
let's get back into that starting
position left foot on that imaginary
line right foot standing in front of it
touch and heel the toe so stay in this
position with your arms down at your
sides right do you have any questions
regarding this position no okay so stay
in this while I explain the rest of it
okay okay so for this test I'm going to
have to take nine steps along that
imaginary line turn around taking a
series of small steps and then take nine
Heel To Toe steps back along that line
okay so Heel To Toe steps nine there
turn around nine back so I'll
demonstrate that for you now so you're
in that starting position so remain in
it you're going to take nine Heel To Toe
steps along that line forward take turn
around take nine heel toe steps back
just going to look like this one two
three counting out loud and so on until
you get to nine on your ninth step
you're going to turn around taking a
series of small steps keeping your front
foot planted so it's going to look like
this and then you're going to take nine
Heel To Toe steps back along that
imaginary line so counting down looking
at your feet one two three and so on
until you get to nine all right okay so
I'm just going to reiterate a couple
things for you when you're doing this
test I want you to look down at your
feet count out loud keep your arms at
your side and don't stop until you've
completed the test do you understand
until I gets a KN until you've complet
the entire test so nine there turn
around taking a series of small steps
with your front foot planted nine Heel
To Toe steps back you have any questions
regarding any of that mm no okay give me
one second and then you can start
okay
all right actually let's get a brighter
flashlight so you can
see all right you can
begin one 2 three four 5 6 7 8
9 one 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 very good all right we're going to do
one more test in a second ask you to
write something down real quick you're
doing good
[Applause]
though okay so for this last one kind of
like that same starting position we had
you in for the other one I'll have you
stand with so put your feet together
arms out at your sides like this and
then don't start until I tell you to
begin the test do you understand do you
have any questions with that no all
right so when I do tell you to begin
you're going to lift either foot so your
choice approximately 6 in off the ground
so it's about the height of a smash soda
can you're going to keep your leg
straight and your foot parallel with the
ground you're going to have your arms at
your side still I'm going to have you
count out loud look down at your feet in
the following manner it's be like a
1,001 1,002 1,003 and so on until I tell
you to stop so again leg straight foot
parallel with the ground approximately 6
in up keep your arms at your side when
you're doing that again I know I've
reiterated a couple times but just look
down at your foot hands at your sides
count out loud and don't stop until I
tell you to okay okay do you have any
questions regarding that so I'm going to
get a timer out on my phone which I
don't have on me so I'll just use my
Watch okay and give me one
second
you help yeah my watch is not working
with me right now do you have your phone
on you ma'am are you ready I'm ready
whenever you are all right so
you good you may
begin sorry you're good I'm just
freezing you're good just make sure you
count out loud Keep Your Arms by your
sides okay
okay one mississipp 2 mississipp
mississipp four
Mississippi five Mississippi 6
Mississippi 7 Mississippi 8 Mississippi
Mississippi 10
Mississippi sorry oh keep going still
got time do you want me to start over no
just keep
going okay so then you're good on that
one okay so we're done with that test
sorry you're good all right so for
tonight you are going to be under arrest
for ow okay okay so I'm going to have
and put your hands behind your
back
all right do you have any weapons drugs
bombs anything on you I should know
about before I search you here okay
we're going to have you stand right in
front of this car while I do
that can you look towards me open your
mouth move your tongue on around
okay
you mind unlocking the door for me
yeah all right just watch your head as
you're getting on
in all right I'm going to close this
door watch your knee okay
okay I'm going have you step on out
we're going to have you take a seat over
there so we'll go around this way to the
right you'll take a seat um I'm going to
take one of your hands out from behind
handcuffs and handcuff into the wall do
you prefer what hand you what hand do
you write with I usually write with my
right hand usually write with your right
okay we'll take your left out pen or
your right out pen no worries whatever
you
want just much more comfortable for you
know if this would like to work with
me there we are right you want just put
this hand on top of your head for
me and then we're going to bring this
other hand around
I'm going to hook it up to here
okay so like sometimes it can get kind
of pressure on your wrist if you just
like hold up on this so sometimes it'll
like relieve the pressure there okay
okay sounds yep so yeah since you are in
custody I do have to read you your
Miranda Rights before we talk about that
okay noise just give me one
second so probably these uh you have the
right to remain silent anything you uh
say can will be used against you in the
court of law you have the right to
consult with a lawyer before questioning
and to have a lawyer present with you
during questioning if you uh cannot
afford to hire a lawyer one will be
appointed to represent you at a public
expense before or during any questioning
if you so wish if you decide to answer
questions now without a lawyer present
you have the right to stop questioning
and remain silent any time you wish and
the right to ask for a lawyer at any
time you wish including during the
questioning so do you understand each of
these rights yes realizing that you have
these rights are you willing to answer
questions or make a statement yeah okay
so then we can talk about your
medications that you use just give me
one second so I can get my
notebook
SEC so do you know them off the top of
your head um
I'm
and then that's it that's it yeah is
that your normal
amount yeah that's the usual I take
sure and everything did you take like
the correct prescribed amount today
though okay
perfect did it just not mix well with
you're
drinking probably yeah what were you all
drinking
tonight um nothing really water
lemonade
Voda be well I work at
the I was there and then I went to
Walmart to get some groceries and then I
was going back to Carthage College okay
um so were you just you're drinking
there with your friends then thought you
were I was just there with my friends
just there with your friends bartender
bouncer I'm a bartender though bartender
okay did you just start bartending there
or when did you start bartending there I
started bartending there in like June
June were you bartending with your
friends like your you your friends go
there and drink and then you bartend um
not
really sure and then it's like I started
there in the summer so some regulars
that came in and then I worked less
during the school year so I haven't
really seen very many people that so
like did you recognize anyone there
tonight or just kind of work into
work yeah just working to work not
really there time did you get down with
work today um
like
6:30 6:30 you went straight to Walmart
got got your whatever you needed and
you're coming back toage 6:30 p.m. today
you got done with work
yeah I have a cat so did you just go
right to Walmart then and then yeah name
bardi bardi I know that's awesome see my
case is even worse now that's just funny
I like that so from work you went right
to Walmart to get groceries and then
headed right home right after work just
like a b and c and then home yeah that's
right for so for winter break it's
technically been
saying I don't really have a place to go
home right now
so sure um with your medication quick
going back to that uh do you take like
when's the last time you took it today
like right away in the morning right
away in the morning you said you take
some of them two times a day so did you
take a second
I never took the second one okay so just
like when approximately in the morning
uh I woke up at like 8:30 so you'd say
it's safe to say around 8:30 took your
medicine
okay then at work drinking or not
drinking no not
drinking just got done with your Shi
went straight to Walmart Straight headed
back home
okay
everyone so I can actually get you on
over
there so I will take you out of these
handcuffs you've been working with us so
y take this
off Rey doesn't need her in these for
the test
right no so you've been working with us
so we're going to work with you okay
okay I promise not to like freak out and
start fighting people the second I get
shot all right so if you want to walk
with me we're going to go over into that
open door that says chemical test with
my partner so we'll go this
way and then if you want to take a seat
in that brown chair right to the
left oh
yeah
all right
so how this is going to
work basically this is this little piece
is going to be this black here what I
you're just going to take a nice deep
breath in just like this and you're
going to blow out in a nice consistent
fashion just like
this like
this
just keep
okay you can move I'm just going to hold
you can move the chair
Clos for there go nice deep
breath keep going keep going keep going
keep going
keep
perfect one more
time
okay
sh
[Applause]
feel
I
knew
can you check if VP got
P perfect
just okay it's we did should have this
phone
number unless I didn't grab it from him
at
n oh
the
legend Sten
winter I'm sure he would love to hear
from
s i
uh when we were learning like the
Spanish in the like in tab he was always
like not paying attention they'd ask him
the questions and I would feed him the
wrong answers and he got so
like say how do you say hands hands up
and I was like Manos Mira he was like
Manos miror and jav's like no that means
hands look and he turns around say
trip that Spanish work though when we
had that
sross on this thing got a lot of checks
and balances that are go through to make
sure it's acting properly so it
take say anything take a deep breath and
[Music]
all right so we're going to have you go
back over to where you were at on the
wall I will cut handcuff your hands back
onto there and then I'll get some
paperwork done for you and we'll get try
and get you moving here
okay you said you WR with that right
hand yep you watch
it thank you so much
yep I
guess
something me tell you just give it to me
straight
.19 what does that mean legal limits 08
blue 1 n so they're a little they're
about twice okay A little over
twice all right this is called the
alcohol influence report um I have to
read you something then you can answer
these questions if You' like okay um so
it's called the pre- interrogation
warning before we ask you any of these
questions just like I read you Miranda
before um you must understand your
rights you have the right to remain
silent anything you say can and will be
used against you in court you have the
right to talk to a lawyer before
questioning and to have a lawyer with
you during any questioning or with you
during questioning if you cannot afford
a lawyer and want one a lawyer will be
appointed to appointed for you without
charge prior to any questioning uh if
you change if you decide to start
answering questions at this time you can
stop anytime during the questioning so
it's a waiver of Rights I have have read
or have had read to me this statement of
my rights I understand what my rights
are I'm willing to answer questions at
this time I do not want a lawyer I
understand what I'm doing would you be
willing to answer some questions right
now I have one question he said I was
good to go out a ride so we'll explain
that to you yeah I'll explain to you
real quick so basically you have to go
through the process right so you have to
go in there you have to get your finger
fingerprints take me see your photos
done everything like that they're going
to let you make a phone call in there
and then you can contact whoever you
need to contact okay you need to get
numbers out of your phone they're more
than happy to let you do that okay so we
just had we just had paperwork to finish
up and then we'll go inside okay we're
trying to get there's obviously a lot
that goes on here so would you be
willing to answer some questions here
yeah okay um I will have you sign right
there where it says
signature all right perfect and then I'm
going to answer some questions um and
then just answer them to the best of
ability okay let me put the time down
first okay so we're you operating a
motor vehicle
yes uh what street or Highway were you
on I have no I have no idea what
was I was trying to get to sharidan
that's for
sure well you where were you going um I
was trying to get back to Carriage
College
where were you coming
from what is today's
day December 18th I think oh December
18th I
think can you know what time it
is uh past 2
I think some some place past 2 a.m. I
think I'm not
sure uh when did you last
sleep um I woke up at like 8:30 this
morning how much sleep did you
have prob probably about 8 hours I would
say is that your normal amount of
sleep yeah usually yeah um are you under
a doctor's care at the moment probably
what does that mean uh that's just kind
of a question I don't know it seems like
like do you have someone that you meet
with every day and have to check in with
them I usually meet with the doctor like
once every 3 weeks I'm probably once a
month so so yeah you're not under the
doctor's okay no um have you taken any
prescription medication SL drugs in the
last 24 hours yes and for what
and then what's the time and date of
last use you said this morning when you
woke up probably about 8:30 I I don't
know the exact time 8:30
9:00 um have you been to the dentist in
the past 24 hours
no do you have bird like Asal intestine
problems oh
no do you have diabetes no are you
taking insulin
no uh were you injured recently uh
no uh do you have any physical defects
that's like missing one hand and Miss
finger again these are just standardized
questions no worries have you been
drinking um yes
how much did you
drink um I'm not sure how much a couple
white cloths
okay like two or
three do you know what time you started
drinking at not sure then what time you
stopped drinking not true not
yeah
[Applause]
where were you
drinking uh with whom were you
drinking um I wasn't really really
drinking with
anybody
have you been using drugs
no um from the last time that you
operated a motor vehicle have you been
drinking or using
drugs what does it mean from the last
time so like when we were talking with
you when you got out of the car have you
used drugs from within then like then to
now again these are just standardized
questions no CU is I'm just trying to
understand them no worries no you're
good that's that's completely fine are
you under the influence of alcohol or
drugs at this time um
alcohol uh were you involved in a class
today
no okay that answers that I will go
ahead